all right so let's finish up we talked
very briefly about how
um knowing these symmetries makes your
integration
very simple because like i said if i had
uh symmetrical boundaries like
negative two and two i would know
because this is an odd function
that the area that's bounded by those
the negative is going to exactly cancel
out with the positives like we saw
earlier
so that's with integration but you can
also see some really cool stuff
with these needed functions if you think
about
derivatives okay so let's suppose
let f of x let's suppose it's an odd
function
okay so therefore i know that f of
negative x equals negative f
of x what can i say about the derivative
f
dash of x if i know this fact well this
is one of those places where
even though it was very inefficient to
use earlier on we still taught you how
to differentiate things by first
principles when you're in a hurry you
don't differentiate things by first
principles because it takes a long time
but if you try and develop new
understanding there's few better places
to go
to return to the foundations and it's
going to be exactly the same case here
so here's what i'm going to do i'm going
to use first principles on
this f of x but i'm going to keep in the
back of my mind
this fact that i know because f x is odd
all right let's have a go at this
so if i want f dash x which is the
derivative right
going back to first principles is this
awkward fraction thing right it's the
limit
as h approaches 0 of take a breath
f of x plus h minus f of x
all divided by h and if you want to
think back what this is really looking
at is
a vertical change a rise divided by a
horizontal
change a run so this is just a fancy way
to say gradient
at a point right which is special
because usually a gradient requires
a start and an end point so this is the
gradient over a single point which is
weird that's why calculus
lets us do special things so if that's
what f dash x
is by definition well all this stuff
with oddness and evenness
is about substituting in negative values
of that same value of x right so what
would happen if i substitute in
negative x let's have a go i'm going to
get the limit
as h approaches 0 of f
here we go the first x that i'm going to
substitute is
negative x plus h and then i'm going to
subtract
f of negative x there's my substitutions
and then i'm going to divide through by
h okay now what can i do
with this well on the first blush like
the easiest thing to have a look at is
this guy along the end here right f of
negative
x because i know that f of x is odd i
can make a substitution there right i
can say
hold on a second instead of writing this
as negative
or minus i should say f of negative x
i can substitute that for negative
negative f of x are you convinced by
that do you see that this
this substitution from
here to here is the definition
of an odd function okay and i still have
this minus sign here
that was from the original first
principles okay
so that's what i can do with that right
hand part of
the numerator what can i do with the
left hand part well
it's not as immediately obvious but we
can
actually do some simplification here
right
if what i do is i'm going to write this
as a negative as a factorization now you
might think why would i factor that
because i don't have a negative for both
of the terms in there well
just stay with me okay if i factor out
here a negative
from inside here what do i get
well i take the negative out of the x
which leaves me just with x
when i factor a negative out of a
positive you get left with a negative
because
two negatives combine to make a positive
so i'm going to get minus
h here okay now think about this
carefully a lot just happened
in there in fact i'm just going to make
this a little clearer by just making the
the colors the same
um so i deleted more than i wanted to
that's better
all right so this negative x plus h i
have
factored out a negative like so here we
go
and hopefully you can convince yourself
if you went in the reverse direction
if you went and expanded that set of
brackets that i have down in here right
the negative with the x would give you
this negative x and then the negative
with the negative h would give you the
plus h okay
i know that seems weird why would you do
that well hold on to your hats for the
next step now i have the denominator
there over
h that hasn't changed at all okay now
what's going on
here well let's tidy this up a little
bit
i can see here with my limit as h
approaches zero for starters
on the end there we started with that
first you've got two negatives right so
that negative plus negative gives you
plus f
of x okay can you see how i did that i'm
again
following from this negative and this
negative combining into a positive
all right now what do i get from this
left hand part the green part
well because f is an odd function that's
where we started with
all the way up here right f is odd
therefore
f of negative something is the same of
negative
f of that same something right now i
have f of negative something
right here f of negative
x minus h so therefore this x minus h
is going to stay on the inside and this
negative is going to creep out
to the outside i can bring it out
because f
is odd so therefore i'm going to write
this f
or minus rather f of x
minus h hm
this would be mysterious again that
denominator is just hanging out there
not doing anything else now my limit
hasn't
been evaluated there so i'm just going
to leave that as the case
now what have i got here how can i work
with this
and make it any better well i've got a
negative first and a positive second we
don't tend to write things like that
you know rather than saying negative 2
plus 5 it would be much easier to think
of this as just 5 take away
2. so the same way i'm going to
rearrange these i'm going to write
i'll stay with the same colors that i'm
using that would be a clever thing to do
this
f of x which is positive i'm going to
write it in first so
that gives me this guy here and then
i've got
this minus f of x minus h i'm going to
write that
over here because it's negative so minus
f of x minus h all divided
by h okay now believe it or not
i actually have finished doing all my
algebraic simplification
this is my final line and you might
think but what does this mean what was
the point of this
well we need to go back to what first
principles
is in the in like what is the whole
point of it right
this guy here by definition right what
does it mean
well if i draw you a little rough sketch
here right
it's if you've got some kind of function
like like so okay
i'm going to copy this because it'll be
useful later
there we go what we're doing is we're
comparing two spots here
like a spot like this call this
x and then we go forward a little bit
and we call that little bit
h so if we go forward by
h we get x plus h right
so i'm going forward h and then i
compare not just their x values
but their y values right that gives me f
of x
over there on the y axis and this guy
here correspondingly
gives me f of x plus h
because it came from an x value of x
plus h over here
okay now what i'm doing is like i said
before i'm comparing rise
over run so what i'm getting is the
gradient
does he the gradient of this section of
the line here
as that section as that interval gets
tinier and tiny and tinier
as h approaches zero right
so all i'm doing is i'm comparing an x
value
and going a little bit further over x
value plus a little bit
so that's x and x plus h what does that
mean
for this well like i said i knew that
function would be
that drawing will be handy from before
what would this fraction that i've got
here
mean well i'm going to be comparing
the same thing an x value let's do a
dotted like i had before
but then i'm not going x plus h i'm
going
x minus h so instead of going
in this positive direction by h i'm
going in the negative direction
by h so that lands me at x
minus h that's this coordinate here so
that lands me over here
and then i'm comparing
this f of x here with the previous y
value
f of x minus h now you can see this is
still going to give me
a gradient calculation it's still rise
over run
it's still y2 take away y1
divided by x2 take away x1 it's just
that
i'm looking to the left rather than to
the right so in other words
this guy here even though it is less
familiar this is just another way of
saying
it's the derivative it's the gradient
function
so what have i got here on the left hand
side what we started with
was f of negative x it's equal to
f sorry i should say f dash of negative
x is equal to f
dash of x which is the very algebraic
definition
of evenness so
if you differentiate an odd function you
get
an even function which brings us all the
way back to this guy
over here you might recall it's all the
way over there it's okay
that i started with i'm going to put
both of them on now i start with sine of
x
right let's hide that now this guy here
is an odd function and if you
differentiate
sine you get cos cosine which is
this guy here an even function so you
can see
even though this is not a polynomial and
so the evenness oddness language is a
bit sort of where is it coming from
it still fits the same behavior that we
can recognize here
and you know even though this is a long
and very detailed proof here
you can prove yourself really easily if
you take you know derivative of x
cubed this is the derivative of an odd
function gives you 3x
squared oh look right there we're
looking at the power
this coefficient over here on this left
hand side
doesn't really matter just changes where
you are you know in terms of scale
this is the part i'm interested in you
differentiate non-function you get an
even one
and i'll leave it to you as an exercise
to the reader to try and do
the reverse if you differentiate an even
function
you get an odd function so i hope that
all
makes sense we covered a lot of ground
the big idea is that functions have
symmetry
right and that symmetry can be very
useful particularly when we're
integrating because it can save you a
lot of work or make your integral a lot
easier
we looked at these two definitions a
geometric one
thinking about reflection and rotation
and an algebraic one using our function
notation
here the names as we saw even symmetry
and odd symmetry come from the
polynomials with those respective powers
we saw the different ways you could
combine symmetries either by addition or
multiplication and the results you would
get
and then lastly we saw when you
differentiate an odd function you get an
even one
and like i said i'll let you prove that
the the reverse
is also true so in summary when you're
looking out uh when you're doing you
know integration or any other kinds of
functions
look out for functions with symmetry
because they can make things
a lot easier for you